children a lot of ways was a pretty
conventional economist he was trained at
MIT in the late 60s and early 70s his
dissertation advisor was Franco
Modigliani who actually co-authored a
couple of papers that sort of led the
way to the rise of rational market
finance and economics so it wasn't like
he was being edited I mean it wasn't
like he was being educated by a bunch of
hippies out in an ashram or something he
was getting a very mathematical
conventional economic education but at
the same time I mean really as I tell it
in the book it this this idea Rose kind
of simultaneously and there was a lot of
cross-pollination at MIT in Chicago but
at MIT there was always this sense of
here's this great model for
understanding how the market works and
also we totally agree that the market is
pretty hard to outsmart we don't know
that it's smart but it is hard for other
people to outsmart but we were not so
sure that means that it's all working
perfectly whereas it Chicago it became
this project to sort of show how great
markets were and how much better they
were than any government bureaucrat so
follow along at MIT from the beginning
it was this weird coexistence of these
very rationalist theories of how the
world worked coupled with this kind of
understanding and a lot of classroom
discussion about how the world didn't
work quite the way it was described in
the mathematical models in the classroom
and so you got people coming out of MIT
and Schiller's classmate Robert Merton
Nobel Prize winner very sort of the high
priest for a while of this rationalist
finance was there at the same time and
came out with a very different world
view so Shiller came out with this
conventional training but this sense
that all these theories and models
weren't entirely right and any and he
had a lot of computer skills & P racal
skills and so he started during the 70's
to just try to test some of these
theories about market behavior against
the data and initially he was looking at
bond prices and and didn't come up with
anything all that explosive but then
starting to late 70s he started looking
at stock prices and was trying to come
up with a measure of whether they
reflected the fundamental value of the
stocks themselves and so he just
compared stock prices to dip to
subsequent dividend payments and found
that the dividend payments were a lot
less volatile than the stock price
movements and that wasn't proof of
anything a lot of people argued well
companies try to keep their dividends
smooth therefore it should mean that
much but other people did similar
examinations of earnings comparing them
with stock prices and basically the
lesson was there seemed to be a lot of
unexplained volatility in the stock
market and and later on other people
including some pretty conventional
finance scholars like Richard roll at
UCLA basically confirmed Schiller's
observation and so Schiller then he
actually went and paid paying attention
to real estate for about 10 years but
when he came back to paying attention to
the stock market again in the mid to
late 90s it was just with this idea that
there were these periods when prices
went off in directions that had less to
do with anything going on with the
fundamentals then I just then mood
swings and and so that that sort of led
him by the late 90s to be this really
prominent doubter about the bull market
of those days and then he came out with
I mean it was he totally admits this was
luck but with the most spectacularly
time book of all time in march two
thousand published irrational exuberance
and march two thousand one is exactly
when that exuberance started to tail off
and end
so he wrote irrational exuberance in two
thousand and then he went back to paying
attention to real estate and wrote a new
version the book that came out in 2005
making the point that Wow real estate
prices had gone really crazy by
historical standards and we could
probably expect sometime in the next few
years a collapse in real estate prices
and and so he's now even more of a guru
than ever before because he really did
it some level predict what happened not
not in the details not at the timing but
he at a time when conventional wisdom
was that the real estate market was not
a big danger he was saying it every day
what's interesting about chiller is his
lesson that he takes from all this is
not that we somehow need to shut down
markets or regulate them vastly more
heavily I mean I think you'd be in favor
of somewhat more regulation but he seems
to think that if only we had even more
financial products if we could all if
we're all buying and selling real estate
derivatives betting that our house
prices might fall then we would have
been better off so in in it sort of
comes back around to that mit belief in
markets and conventional economics in
the end he so he in any he goes in he's
very often paired with naseem to leb and
options trader turned sort of
bomb-throwing market philosopher and
Shiller comes across as the conservative
or the moderate and all of those
discussions now
I mean his belief is continued growth of
the financial system is a good thing we
just have these shake out swear we
figure out what doesn't work I guess my
one caveat to that because then I after
he said that I went back and was trying
to look at a lot of it because finance
professors always bring this up that
there's a lot of comparative global
research showing the countries with
better developed financial systems do
better than those without them but it's
mostly research about developing
countries and and it sort of stands to
reason that a company where nobody has a
country where nobody has a bank account
is not going to progress as fast
economically as one where their banks
and loans available but I don't know
that I think once you get to a well
developed economy with big financial
system I'm sure there's some point of
diminishing returns and it's pretty
clear we reach that in the US over the
past decade where you get a financial
system that sort of takes on a dynamic
of its own and is no longer serving the
economy as a whole but it's just kind of
churning for its own benefit and and and
kind of sucking off lots of money from
the system so and I imagine we will
start getting a lot of research now
about whether there is any way to tell
what what's that point where your
financial system has gotten too big and
i don't think Schiller would disagree
with that he just in the end still
believes in finance and that it can do
good things for people